congrats on the movie uh a million
questions
if someone has actually never seen the
movies you've made or read the books
that you've written what's the first
thing you want them reading or watching
oh my god i don't know i'm i'm shooting
a film at the moment
and
there's several of the crew i really get
on with and they really like me i think
and they think i'm like a really nice
sort of normal uh guy and i say please
don't watch any of the films i've made
otherwise it will destroy our good close
working relationship so
if nobody's ever seen any of that stuff
before i never encourage anybody to see
anything i've done i've never handed
anyone a book i've written or said watch
my film
i think they'll look at me differently
i think the films are kind of weird and
i'm actually really kind of normal or
whatever the [ __ ] normal
do you actually have a lot of unproduced
screenplays in your desk well you know
this film
uh
men
um as it happens
i
wrote a first draft of this film maybe
15 years ago could be more
i think i wrote the first draft between
sunshine and never let me go which is
quite a long time ago i don't know how
many years ago was a long time ago and
um
it had
one to
at least
three and maybe four
completely different
incarnations before this one which is
either the fourth or fifth
so in some respects i do have a lot of
i i have a lot of uh unmade uh
screenplays in the drawer as it were but
i quite often rework them
and they change over time um
uh
x machina i remember
had a very very different first
incarnation
this film had a very different
incarnation dredd had many incarnations
so
so i always sometimes i talk to writers
and they
you know they work on a screenplay and
they feel it hasn't got there yet or
they can't get it financed or whatever
the thing is and i just say just put it
aside
and start working on the next one
because
the thing when you put it in a drawer
isn't dead
it can come back in any number of
different ways and uh
so short answer is yes and that what
proceeded was the long answer before
getting into the film one last thing if
you get the financing to make anything
you want
uh what would you make and why right now
nothing i'm thinking i'm going to stop
directing for a while i've done a bunch
of stuff back to back and i need a
indeterminate break
men and the film i'm shooting at the
moment bumped right up against each
other the last day of post on men was 48
hours before the first day of principal
photography on the movie i'm shooting at
the minute in
atlanta and um
i just need to stop for a bit to be
honest i kind of like the idea of
writing for someone else to direct
there's a couple of directors out there
who've approached me saying are you
interested in that um
uh and
um
they're very
sort of you know nothing fancy it's not
like a marvel movie or something
very very small indie projects and
right now that's what i'm thinking about
doing i'm a fan of your work with rob
hardy uh
who have you worked with non-stop what
was it about his work for that you saw
that said uh i want to work with him on
ex machina and how has the relationship
blossomed on all the projects rob and i
just i i really think we work very well
together uh
um i think both of us are kind of spiky
and i'm not sure how well we'd work with
other people or like i don't know but we
work really well with each other
we we have
a lot of shorthand so
he he can describe a shot that he's
spotted or demonstrated to me very very
easily and very quickly i trust him a
lot uh i like him a lot um he's got he's
got a really really good eye and a very
good attitude on set these shoots are
always hard for one reason or another
and he
he never complains he always does
beautiful work he's a lovely man
and you know what
that in a way isn't the answer to your
question what did i first see i just saw
the frames and i thought that's how
uh that looks beautiful that looks smart
and he doesn't overdo it so he doesn't
he doesn't try and kind of uh over bake
a shot by making it kind of
too
uh in your face beautiful photography
he's got quite a lot of restraint so in
some ways i think he doesn't get the
credit he deserves because he's not
showy
um
uh he's often kind of understated uh and
i i love that i really like the the uh
the stuff in the past and men that is
shot with this great uh i think you shot
it with two cameras and you it's um it's
like at the sunset and the use of color
is so
like good uh can you sort of talk about
uh the color scheme that you wanted to
go for um in the film really simple
really simple color scheme which was red
and green really
and
we used
we used red in very selective places and
then we
timed our shoot we had a really
complicated thing to do with the timing
of the shoot but where we were up
against the wire on all sorts of things
but we pushed it to literally the last
possible day we could start shooting
because we were waiting for spring to
arrive and for the leaves to turn green
and in fact
when in the first couple of weeks of
shooting all the trees looked like
winter trees and uh we were waiting for
the green to kind of explode out which
it did thank goodness um
and uh so the color scheme was really
about red and green and it was about um
uh yeah red spaces and green spaces and
then what we did was was not be
coy about it
so not like a little flash of green or a
little flash of red but go red go green
sort of go
go hard i guess one of the things that i
love about movies is when they don't
explain everything this film definitely
doesn't explain everything did you have
any pressure from like a24 or producers
to maybe explain more or did they know
going in that this is what i want to do
i i had no pressure at all um
i think that in
the
sort of earlier on in my
uh film making life i was under a lot of
pressure the whole time to explain
um
from all sorts of different areas it
wouldn't just be studios it could be
creatives it could be people
sort of involved in a sort of you know
sort of at the coal face side of it on
on set or wherever
and
it was never really my taste i always
uh
listen filmmaking is a really broad
church there's space for lots of
different kinds of films and i'm not i'm
not saying there's a wrong way or a
right way to make films but i like films
that you have to lean into and as a
viewer you have to kind of participate
in them it's not all provided for you
you have to imaginatively participate in
the film and
for it to work
and that means not answering all
questions in some respects not not spoon
feeding everything and but i think at
this point
i mean it's i don't know nearly quarter
of a century i think i've been doing
this now and
uh
i think people kind of know
uh
you know they they know
yeah if this guy writes the script it's
probably going to be a bit like that not
so much like this and
so
there was definitely a point where i was
always disappointing people
they'd they sort of felt oh if you just
did this this and this it would get over
the line it would be better like why
can't you just do that and so the films
would always be
smaller sort of not commercially
successful or whatever the thing would
be but now i think they're like yeah no
i get it so they they know what they're
financing and a24 has been
uh truly
nothing except supportive
um
uh
i
at every step along the way uh
pre-production through to the edit and
listen it's quite a challenging film so
i'm grateful for that i watched the q a
yesterday and i couldn't believe that
attack on titan uh influenced this film
uh and you shared that story now for
people that didn't get to see the q and
a can you sort of talk about how that
film uh i mean how about how attack on
titan um
yeah th there's a there's a there's a
sequence in the film uh at the end of
the film which i won't describe because
it would kind of blow it i guess but
but
in the writing of it it was it was
written in terms of mutations
and film has kind of a long history with
mutations american werewolf or david
cronenberg or there's all sorts of you
know uh the thing all sorts of
of uh prosthetics and vfx and forms of
mutation and
uh
and you know it we were just about to go
into pre-production and i was struggling
with all of the imagery and not not
feeling it and
feeling concerned and my daughter and i
uh she had got me hooked on attack on
titan um
really
incredibly impressive
uh um anime
on so many levels it impressed me on so
many levels
and um
i
one of the things i noticed was how
clever it was in terms of
creating strange depictions of the human
form and it did something really
brilliant which is it it verges right on
the edge of ridiculous
it sort of leans into the ridiculous
and uh
and yet makes them terrifying and
strange and intimidating and
i thought that is
you know
20 30 40 times more imaginative than
anything i've got going on in my head at
the moment it's more imaginative than
anything i'm thinking of and
it's also simpler
what they're doing is very very simple
it's it's sort of perfectly judged and
what it did was i i think what attack on
titan did was it made me raise my game
it made me go back and think harder and
uh and come up with with a completely
different idea for the mutation sequence
that ended up then
being extremely appropriate at least for
me appropriate to
to to some of the sort of themic
concerns within the film um so i guess
that's the answer i just think attack on
titan's really good and anytime you see
something good it makes you raise your
game that's what i think you think oh
okay right i better not be lazy look at
this stuff i agree thank you so much for
your time sir uh until the next one uh
again i you know thank you for making
movies thanks man i appreciate it good
to see you again
you